when over the last 40 years since the
time we started our Galapagos research
there have been two or three major
changes in general understanding of how
evolution works the first is a big
development in computer technology which
is allow people to analyze large
quantities of data the second one is a
very large development in molecular
genetics which has given many biologists
the tools to examining evolution at
genetic level and the third one is the
fuel studies that have been done that
allow people to understand just how
rapidly evolution takes place not over
centuries not over decades but over a
short period of time such as a year for
organisms as large as birds the general
theory of evolution has changed very
little what actually has changed is the
techniques that have allowed us to study
it and one of the biggest ones is the
genetic technique so now that we are
able to sequence whole genomes we've
been able to look at the genes and that
are responsible for some of the changes
that we have seen in the field so this
has been extremely exciting and so it is
more that we are able to go in depth to
a much greater degree than they were
before